[Music]
when a tile Falls from your roof it's an
opportunity to see 10,000
Stars a good friend is better than a
near
[Music]
relation one door is shut but a thousand
are open
a Man Who develops himself is twice
born the tongue that belongs to a fake
friend is sharper than a
[Music]
knife a dog that always barks gets
little
[Music]
attention abundance breeds
arrogance
dress a monkey in silk and it is still a
[Music]
monkey if a man lends an ear it is
because he too wants to
speak what is greatly desired is not
believed when it
comes to in Harmony are in God's
company the the person who learns well
also defends himself
well if you have a tail of straw then
keep away from the
fire it's not the gay coat that makes
the
gentlemen the larger the ship the larger
storm you can only take out of a bag
what was already in
it the revolution is not an apple that
falls when it is ripe you have to make
it
fall wretched are those who are
vindictive and
spiteful when you work hard you are not
going to be happy the whole time you are
going to have frustration and hard times
[Music]
as a coach the greatest passion you can
have is for improving your
[Music]
players only by living absurdly is it
possible to break out of this infinite
[Music]
absurdity you need great Passion because
everything you do with great pleasure
you do
well we know we cannot plant seeds with
closed fists to seow we must open our
[Music]
hands if something's important to you
you make time for
it live your life not celebrating
victories but overcoming
defeats the true revolutionary is Guided
by great feelings of love
be realistic demand The
Impossible we have no right to believe
that freedom can be won without
[Music]
struggle let the world change you and
you can change the
[Music]
world one has to grow hard without ever
losing
tenderness
to accomplish much you must first lose
[Music]
everything silence is argument carried
out by other
means words without Deeds are
worthless a country that does not know
how to read and write is easy to
deceive
we cannot be sure of having something to
live for unless we are willing to Die
For
[Music]
It homesickness Starts with
Food the life of a single human being is
worth a million times more than all the
property of the richest man on
earth people are mostly animals fighting
for Domination and
survival past Waters can't move
Mills Love is Blind so you have to feel
your
way don't hang your hat higher than you
can
reach to satisfy a niche all you have to
do is
begin
[Music]
he who knows nothing doubts
nothing some bad things come for
[Music]
Good Good Will makes the road
shorter don't carry all your eggs in one
basket there's no good that lasts
forever or evil that never Never
Ends don't call the alligator a big
mouth till you have crossed the
[Music]
river old monkeys don't put their hand
in a
jar he who tells a tale tells his own
version of
[Music]
it others will measure you with the same
Rod you use to measure
them the devil takes what you've earned
undeservedly water can break the hardest
Stone necessity makes the frog
jump in a closed mouth flies can't
enter it's a it's a sad thing not to
have friends but it is even sadder not
to have
enemies He Who Loves You Will Make You
[Music]
Weep tell me who you walk with and I'll
tell you who you
are everything is funny as long as it is
happening to somebody
else pepper in someone else's eyes is a
[Music]
refreshment those who risk nothing don't
eat the bird that follows a bat will
wake up upside
down two roosters don't fit on a
[Music]
perch a scolded cat fears cold water
don't place the cart before the
oxen those who eat and Save The
Leftovers set the table
[Music]
twice woman is like your Shadow follow
her she flies fly from her she
follows the house with a good foundation
fears no
wind there's no evil that doesn't bring
some
good no matter how early you rise the
day won't Dawn any
sooner he who grasps too much holds
little the shrimp that sleeps gets
Carried Away by the current
[Music]
let foolish words fall on deaf
ears those who are absent often are soon
forgotten raise crows and they'll pluck
out your
eyes the baby that doesn't cry doesn't
get
fed The Habit doesn't make the
monk good face in bad
times no bad thing lasts a 100 years nor
does a body to endure
it Jack of all trades master of
none you can't cover the sun with a
finger
One Nail drives out
another the more things change the more
they stay the
same hunger is the best
[Music]
seasoning the wise man learns more from
his enemies than the fool from his
friends patience is the mother of all
[Music]
virtues the fox that can't reach the
grapes says they're
sour there's no rule without an
exception the road of excess leads to
the Palace of
[Music]
wisdom he who is born a donkey never
becomes a horse
those who won't hear watch out will hear
poor
[Music]
thing no woman can make a wise man out
of a fool but every woman can change a
wise man into a
[Music]
fool if advice were a good thing people
would sell it not give it
away when the offering is too big the
saint will become
suspicious to love and not be loved is
time poorly
spent it's not the fault of the pig but
of the one who scratches its
back
[Music]